[Music]
so this is huge news it's not a joke and
it's coming from you guys
wow go figure it out that's cool that's
entirely accurate all right all right
buddy what is it all right we're
announcing the first week of guests
show starting november 8th
oh yeah
so so you've been watching you've been
uh sitting through the questions but now
you're getting a huge
beautiful reveal remarkably really
but there actually will be uh payoff
that's right here okay you ready you
gotta get the paper there we go all
right this is amazing look at that code
if i could flap i would do it i'll
that's great all right so
all right let's do it here we go okay
show number one first guess for show
number one actual guest
the first guest will be
[Music]
we're having a poll you can vote for the
first guest just go to teamcoco.com
first guest poll
and vote for your who you want to be the
first guest and that's who our first
guest on november 18th so you
you get to pick you can be anywhere
that's right
that's great you get to pick who the
first guest is the second guest the
second second guest big big stop
[Music]
you are the green puppet he is the green
oh i got a full night's
i'm a little more amazed unbelievable
that sounds like an amazing show
and rounding out the first show
musical
guess
jack white
[Music]
jack white that is amazing our first
show will be the first guest winner seth
rogen and then musical guest jackpot
that is first show
oh yeah
oh yeah second show hit him with the
second show second show
first guest big star
tom hanks
tom hanks
comments actor
hilarious good guy great hair tom hanks
and our good buddy juanito
and musical guest
sound gun second show sound garden time
hence jack
sound gun on the second show
first shot third amazing
a little guy maybe you know him his
name's john hamm
he's a good looking yep but he's not
he's got it
really he's best yes really good looking
who's the second guest charlene
charlene
very very very very funny very funny
and music
fistful of mercy oh yeah not just that's
a cup full of fistfuls that's right and
you guys like bands with the oven i'm
sorry that's full of mercy that's right
ben harper and uh danny harrison joseph
awesome heck of a band heck of a bad
supergroup someone said super super
group that's right for our super first
week and the third uh the fourth show
thursday round day of the week oh boy
here we go we got michael sarah michael
michael sarah modern family julie bowen
julie bowen and comedian john dawes john
finishing that off with some great
comedy man that sounds like a great week
i love it so that's your first week
ladies and gentlemen it's pretty awesome
by puppets but doesn't mean it's that's
true